in the previous video we have seen what
duality means for convex sets
and what duality means for convex
functions
in this video we will see what duality
means for convex optimization problems
and we will see how it can be helpful
for designing efficient algorithms
for solving these problems
[Music]
let's work with an example this time
imagine you are the captain of a ship
in the middle of the ocean using some
sophisticated equipment
you know that the rain is coming from
some direction c for example
c equals the vector 1 1. so you decide
to steer the ship
in the opposite direction as much as
possible
you also remember that the sea is
infested with sharks
except for a safe circular region
of radius one unit this now becomes an
optimization problem
our decision variable is the
two-dimensional vector x
that represents the position of the ship
our objective is
c transpose x or in other words x one
plus x
and we have a single constraint which is
that we need to pick x
from the unit disk
note that this is a convex optimization
problem because the objective function
is linear
and in particular convex and the
constraint is given by
a convex function one thing we would
love to do
is somehow get rid of the constraint
indeed
if this constraint did not exist then we
would just have an unconstrained
convex optimization problem and we have
discussed those in detail
in the previous video and the nice way
to visualize what is going on
in that case is to imagine that the
level of the c
is tilted according to the objective
function
in such a way that low sea levels
correspond to
low objective values and high sea levels
to high objective values
it becomes visually clear that the
answer would simply be
to steer the ship in the direction of
minus c
which matches our intuition so keep this
analogy in mind
for later because it will be useful
but life is unfair and you often need to
deal with constraints
otherwise you become a snack for some
hungry sharks
so one way to get rid of a constraint is
to move it to the objective function via
what is called a penalty function
so what is a penalty function you ask
well
it is simply a function that penalizes
you for not satisfying a constraint
and a natural choice for this penalty
function
is a function that takes the value of 0
when its argument is negative
and the value plus infinity when its
argument is positive
let's call this particular penalty
function the zero infinity penalty for
later references now if you pick an x
that satisfies the constraint
then the penalty term will evaluate to
zero it is as if the penalty term
simply was not there but if you pick an
x that does not satisfy the constraint
then the penalty term will evaluate to
plus infinity
which is really the worst possible
outcome you can hope for
as far as minimization problems are
concerned visually
this penalty function raises the sea
level outside of our disk of safety
to plus infinity so it makes it no
longer
desirable to steer the shape outside of
this circle
even if the original objective value was
smaller there
and this penalty term is almost perfect
we generally get rid of the constraint
without affecting the optimal value of
the minimization problem
the price we pay however is that our
objective function now
can take the value plus infinity and
while we can just replace it with some
really large value like
a million we would still have the issue
that our objective function
has become discontinuous and it would no
longer make sense to take the gradient
of this function for example
one thing we could try here is
approximate this penalty function
with another function that is smooth and
does not take infinite values
the simplest thing we could try here is
to pick a linear function as our penalty
function
something like u times y where the slope
u
is a non-negative number visually
you can see how this penalty is a smooth
approximation
of the zero infinity penalty function
how does this linear penalty work
well the idea is simple if you pick an x
that does not satisfy the constraint
this penalty term will evaluate not to
infinity this time
but to a quantity that is proportional
to how much
you violated the constraint and if you
pick an x that satisfies the constraint
believe it or not you actually get
rewarded
and as much as we like it when we get
rewarded for doing the right thing
and penalize for violating constraints
it is less than ideal in this scenario
because it affects the optimal value of
our minimization problem
and the amount by which it affects the
optimal value
depends on the value of the slope you
clearly for any value of u this linear
approximation is
rather poor but notice that if you
consider
all of the u's and take the maximum
of the corresponding linear penalties
you can check by looking at the plot
that you recover the original zero
infinity penalty function
which is pretty neat right so let's try
to use this maximum
as our penalty function and note that
now
we can take the maximum outside since
x1 plus x2 does not depend on you
what we have now is what is called a min
max problem
and a nice interpretation of what's
going on here is
to view the min max problem as a two
persons game
we have an x player and a u player
the x player picks an x to try to make
this quantity small
while the u player will try to penalize
us if we don't satisfy the constraints
and pku that makes this term big
[Music]
and in games like these it is important
to know who plays first
indeed if given the choice you will
always want to go second
because the second player gets the
benefit of knowing what the first player
did
so here naturally the x player might
protest that it is not fair that he
always goes first
and wonders what happens if the other
player you
goes first for a change well if you goes
first
then the x player's job becomes much
simpler
he just needs to minimize this quantity
and i emphasize here that this quantity
is a convex function
without any constraints so x can just
take the gradient of this quantity
set it to 0 and solve for x
and now that we know what the response
of x should be
we can plug that back in
maximize with respect to u
[Music]
and get the solution x 1 equals x 2
equals
minus square root of 2 over 2. it is
important to note here that
what we have just done is not solve the
original problem
but a variation of it the problem that
we solved is actually called the
dual problem while the original problem
is called the primal problem
and there are a lot of benefits to
considering this dual problem
but before we talk about that let's just
take a step back from this example for a
bit
and see what the dual problem is for
convex optimization problems in general
let us now consider a general convex
optimization problem
and inspired by the example we just saw
let's try to derive its dual
the first step is to get rid of the
constraints
for that multiply each function in the
constraints
with a scalar that represents the slope
of our penalty function
and move these functions from the
constraints to the objective function
and similar to what we did in the
example we are going to take the maximum
over the scalars uis and vi's
for inequality constraints like the ones
we had in the example
we really want the cost to be positive
while for equality constraints
where we want to penalize positive and
negative values alike
we will allow the slope to be positive
or negative
and now to get the dual problem we pull
the maximum outside
and we switch the order of the min and
the max
this quantity here is known in the
literature
as the lagrangian of the optimization
problem
and the dual problem is referred to as
the lagrangian du
and we will go back to the lagrangian in
a second
keywords are in order at this point
first
the dual problem has one variable for
each constraint
of the primer these can be interpreted
as the cost
or price for violating that constraint
second the dual problem gives us a lower
bound
on the optimal value of the primal
problem this is because in the dual
problem
and unlike in the primal problem the x
player
which tries to make our objective
function small goes second
and therefore has the advantage and
finally
and what is more interesting is that
under some mild assumptions
strong duality holds this means that the
optimal value of the primal and the dual
problem
actually coincide so you can solve
whichever you find
easiest and you will find the right
answer
the assumptions i refer to are a bit
technical so i won't list them here
just know that they are usually
satisfied and they are satisfied for our
toe example for instance
anyway we won't worry too much about
that and we're just going to assume from
now on
that strong duality holds
and now that we have derived the dual
problem let's see how it can be useful
for solving convex optimization problems
and this will lead us to the next theme
of this video which is the
celebrated kkt conditions let's consider
our friend the lagrangian again remember
that the x player
tries to minimize this quantity so at
the optimal solution x
the gradient with respect to x better be
zero
this is a necessary condition that any
optimal solution
to the optimization problem should
satisfy
think of it as a generalization of the
condition that grad of f
equals zero for any minimizer of an
unconstrained optimization problem
[Music]
there is a nice geometric intuition
behind this condition
and let's see a visual explanation of
what is happening here
and for simplicity let's consider a case
where we have only one inequality
just like the example we saw before in
which case this condition is saying that
grad f and grad g are inversely
proportional to each other
let us delimit the feasible region given
by g
with a green line and consider an
arbitrary point x
inside this region at this point x
let's draw the gradient of g and the
gradient of f
and remember what gradients represent
when you follow the opposite direction
to the gradient of a function
the value of that function will decrease
at least locally
so we know that in this green rectangle
the value of g
will remain smaller than zero and
therefore
we can safely move x inside of this
region
without fear of violating the constraint
similarly if you nudge x to fall in the
yellow region
you will reduce and hence improve the
objective function f
so if the yellow and green region
intersect
it means that you can nudge your x a bit
stay feasible
and improve the objective value so such
an x cannot be optimal
said differently if x were optimal then
necessarily the two regions should not
intersect
which can only happen if the gradient of
f and g
are inversely proportional to each other
at this point it is a good idea to recap
what we have just seen
we have seen that if x is an optimal
solution
then it should satisfy this gradient
condition
and you might wonder if this condition
is also sufficient
in the sense that if for some point x
you succeeded in finding a scalar u
that makes this condition hold then that
makes x an optimal solution
after all for unconstrained optimization
problems
grad f equals 0 guarantees that x is an
optimal solution
unfortunately it turns out that this
implication is not quite true
and you need additional assumptions on x
and u
to make it old on the bright side
however
these additional assumptions are quite
natural
and they are as follows first and
foremost
we need x to be feasible second the
scalar u should be negative
and last that the penalty term u times g
should be zero only this last condition
is new
and the meaning of this condition is
that at the end of the day
if you choose x and u properly the
penalty term u times g
should not affect the optimal value of
our minimization problem
and hence should be zero these
conditions together
are known as the kkt conditions and
they are extremely important in convex
optimization
the big pro of kkt is that you
essentially reduce
solving an optimization problem to
solving a bunch of equations and
inequalities
and as you can imagine this is extremely
useful
for designing general purpose
optimization solvers
you can try to solve for these
conditions by hand for small examples
like the one we saw earlier
but that easily becomes complicated for
more involved problems so we need to
develop
a more sophisticated machinery
and that is exactly where the interior
point method comes in
[Music]
as i said earlier you can view the
interior point method
as a way to solve the kkkt conditions
there are two big insights or solution
techniques
behind the interior point method and
these techniques are actually useful
for a lot of other problems in
mathematics beyond just optimization
the first insight is that we are not
going to solve the kkt conditions
exactly
but we are going to solve a modified or
perturbed version of these conditions
that we call kkt of t where t
is a positive parameter that controls
the degree of this perturbation and
while we're at it
let's call the solution to these
perturbed equations x of t
and call the solution to the original
equations
x star the perturbation works as follows
we keep all of the kkt conditions the
same
except for the last equation in the
right hand side of this equation
we replace zero with a negative number
minus t
hopefully when t is small x of t and x
star will be close
or in other terms as the perturbation
parameter t goes to zero
x t converges to x star
so far we have talked about how to do
this perturbation
but not why we do this perturbation in
the first place
the main reason behind it is that and as
we will see now
the modified kkt conditions are much
easier to solve
if u times g equals minus t then we
immediately get the value of u
from the value of x as u equals minus t
over g of x
let's plug this value of u back in the
gradient equation
as it turns out this quantity is
actually
the gradient of f minus t of log minus g
and you might want to pause the video
here and work out the gradient by hand
to convince yourselves of this fact
now in order to solve this gradient
equation
we just need to minimize this function
indeed at the point where the minimum is
attained we know that the gradient
must be zero and as a bonus note that if
you succeed in minimizing this function
then the solution that you will find
will automatically satisfy the
constraint
g of x smaller than zero because if
g were positive log minus g would be
plus infinity
and as a bonus of this bonus you will be
automatically positive
so from now on we are in unconstrained
minimization territory
and you can use something like newton's
method to perform this minimization
there is a nice geometric interpretation
behind this minimization problem
it is as if the penalty term for
violating the constraint
was given by the log function and the
scalar t
controls the degree of this penalty
[Music]
the issue here is that we want to take t
to be as small as possible
so that the penalty term doesn't affect
our objective value too much
but taking t to be too small causes
issues
as it makes t times log behave like the
discontinuous zero infinity penalty
function
we saw earlier and practically speaking
what is going to happen is
that newton's method will be extremely
slow to converge
and will cause numerical issues the
second insight
alleviates this issue in a very clever
way
the second insight is that we don't have
to take t to be small right away
but start with a big t and make it
smaller and smaller
let's see why this is a useful strategy
if t
is a very big number then the log term
dominates
and it is as if the first term did not
exist
and because log is increasing this is
the same as
minimizing g of x which you can do by
you guessed it
newton's method in our toy example
this step would give the center of the
disk and
more generally the point you get at this
step is called the analytic center of
the feasible region
once you have a solution for a given t
you can try to solve for a
slightly smaller t prime say t prime
equals
0.9 times t we will again use newton's
method
but now the difference is that we will
specify x of t
as a starting point for newton's method
the one thing you need to know about
newton's method is that
if you initialize it with a point that
is close
to the optimal solution then it will run
super fast
and by design we have that x of t
is close to x of t prime so by
initializing newton from x of t
computing
x of t prime will be easy and
the interior point method will keep
iterating and making t
smaller and smaller in a similar fashion
until a t that is deemed close enough to
zero
is reached so to recap
the two insights we just saw the
interior
point method when applied to a convex
constraint problem
will move constraints to the objective
function via a log penalty function
multiplied by scalar t it will start
with a large t
effectively finding the analytic center
of the feasible set
then it will work its way to t equals 0
by going through the path
formed by the x's of t this path is
called the central path
the central path falls in the interior
of the feasible region
and this is how the interior point
method earned its name
and the end of the central path is the
solution that is eventually returned
by the interior point method
we have now reached the end of this
video series
to conclude let me say that today we
have barely scratched the surface of
convex optimization
there is a lot more to say about duality
and there is a lot more to say about the
interior point method
but hopefully this video has helped to
develop the necessary intuition
so that in the future if you read about
convex optimization in a wikipedia page
or research paper
you're not completely lost and if you
want to dive deeper into the topic
a natural reference i encourage you to
look at is this book by boyd and van der
bee
that i have used personally for
preparing this video and the pdf version
of this book is
freely available online and as always
thank you very much for following along
and see you next time